good afternoon King Charles's State
visit to France this weekend has been
postponed it comes after anti-government
protests in the country over plans to
raise the retirement age erupted in
violence again last night the king had
been due to arrive in France this Sunday
it would have been the first state visit
of his Reign but it's now been canceled
at the request of the French government
we're confirming the news a UK
government spokesperson said the king
and queen consort State visit to France
has been postponed this decision was
taken with the consent of all parties
after the president of France asked the
British government to postpone the visit
a very similar statement as well from
Buckingham Palace which reads the king
and the queen consort State visit to
France has been postponed their
majesties greatly look forward to the
opportunity to visit France as soon as
dates can be found
on our Royal correspondent Laura bundock
is with me hello there to you Laura this
would have been the phone call that
President macron didn't want to have to
make and it's the phone call that the
king wouldn't have wanted to receive
either I think this was a huge moment
for both men really but particularly I
think for the king because it was to be
his first state visit he's visited
France officially as Prince of Wales 35
times but never as Monarch so a lot was
being played into this meeting it was
seen as significant for a number of
reasons because I think if you look at
where Britain is now if you look at the
amount of division the disputes
following brexit this meeting was seen
as a Reconciliation point of view like
reaffirming uh the anglo- French
relationships after so much frostiness
between them that's seen as thoring away
the Windsor framework Now sort of signed
and sealed this was that the two
countries looking forward we're told a
celebration of the relationship between
them but I think meet her very early on
we got a sense yesterday things were
going wrong the word Versailles was
taken out of the official information
about this trip seen as antagonistic to
this a real provocation the wrong place
to be seen having lavish Banquets and
that's where the State Bank it was meant
to be happening so that that was taken
away and then I think as the situation
in France escalated that the nervousness
the twitchiness ramped up to a whole new
level culminating today with the
cancellation of the French leg of this
state visit the German leg still going
German's still going ahead have a listen
now to Lord Ricketts who's the former
Ambassador British ambassador to France
interesting what he has to say
they couldn't for example do the kind of
walkabouts with crowds that the king
enjoys so much what was the point of
doing it really doing a state visit
where the president himself is subject
to enormous criticism
can't really appear in public in any
safety that's not a good circumstance to
do a state visiting
these are live pictures Laura this is
President mackerel he's speaking in
Brussels unrelated to what we're we're
talking about now but as far as we know
that trip will not go ahead until things
calm down absolutely we know that he had
this phone call earlier on with the King
it is a moment of embarrassment for him
but I think they had to assess what is
worse canceling now with just two days
to go or letting this trip go ahead and
face a humiliation of it being
completely overshadowed and dominated by
protesters who would have really taken
this moment and played it to their
absolute Advantage so bad news for
macron and and bad news for the king and
as I say this is not this is not what
Buckingham Palace sort of wanted these
trips have planned and planned and
planned the tiniest of details but
Germany will happen so we don't know
when and we don't know when the French
Trip's being postponed until but we're
assuming the Germany trip which was
meant to start on Wednesday in Berlin
will go ahead ending in Hamburg on
Friday one thing I love about this
though is the fact that this is a
dispute about raising the pension age to
64. the king is 74 and still working
full-time I don't know if that was
mentioned but I think he had much
Sympathy for the strikers potentially
not who knows who knows what they said
but anyway a big change of plan for both
countries and an unexpected hole in his
diary as well all right Laura thank you
very much indeed uh well all of this of
course has been brought about because of
the situation that we've been seeing
there on the streets in Paris and also
other cities around France guys Adele
Robinson has all the latest from Paris
now
um it was a joint decision between
France and the UK and and the Elysee
Palace has released a statement which I
can read to you
um the summary at the top basically is
the decision was taken by both of them
and they said
um it was after a telephone exchange
between the president for the president
and the King himself
um and it was all about being able to
welcome King Charles III in a manner
that is befitting their friendship and
the state visit will of course be
rescheduled as soon as possible
um as I said though inevitable if you
look at the bigger picture last night
saw the biggest night of unrest so far
in these demonstrations since macron's
government pushed through his
controversial pension reform in
Parliament without a vote that has
incensed people on the street
um this morning we wake up to the
figures of more than 400 police officers
injured across France more than 400
arrests 127 of those are still in
custody and uh 14 police officers are in
hospitals seriously injured
um more than 900 fires as well will it
you can see one of them here behind me
was um
uh some Flats a house and it had to be
evacuated it's not a good look is it for
a state visit for the king and that
would have been on their minds it's not
just about security but it's also the
Optics of this critics of macron said
that a big lavish State visit for which
they'll have spent a lot of money is not
compatible
um with the feelings on the street right
now you know last night we were walking
around and there were multiple fires
tear gas was being fired people
um were angled and you know even if a
minority were troublemakers known to the
police they do represent in their way
the feeling of the people the polls show
that more than 70 of French citizens are
against raising the retirement age from
62 to 64. so it's not entirely
surprising this announcement
um and I think as well that critics have
said if the president had gone ahead and
they think ahead with this visit and had
this lavish dinner that was supposed to
be at Versailles but then the word was
that it was going to be changed to the
Elysee price if that had gone ahead
um it doesn't really look well with a
country that at the moment is revolting
in its own way against
um the economic argument of macron that
the country can't afford to carry on
with the pension system so not
surprising
um he will the king as we've had be
continuing with his talk of Germany
um and the Nationwide strikes here in
France will go ahead important to
remember that they're not protesting
over King Charles uh coming here they
are angry about pension reform
um but of course there will be some
discomfort among protesters about macron
visiting uh laying out the red carpet as
it were for the king as such a
disruptive and at times according to you
know if we saw what happened last night
violent time for the country